hey everyone we all know that microsoft
azure is a growing collection of
cloud-based computing services made
available to businesses developers
government agencies and anybody else who
wants to create an app or operate a
website without having to set up and
maintain hardware or server software so
considering this versatility and
popularity of azure simple learn has
brought you a fully fledged azure
tutorial for big news video
in this video i'll take you around
essential azure functionalities and
services and their in-depth concepts
so without doing any further ado let's
start with the video
but before diving deep into its concepts
we'll first take you through the basics
starting with understanding what is
azure how it works and what services it
offers along with their functionality
following that will take you through the
azure tutorial for beginners where you
will learn about azure's various
concepts like its services discussed in
detail along with a proper demonstration
on the microsoft azure console
then we'll take you through azure's
other features provided to us like azure
active directory as your machine
learning as your data factory as your
virtual network tutorial and as your
devops tutorial
with in-depth demos for better
understanding
then we'll have a crisp comparison
between aws azure and gcp
then we'll look into some popular azure
certifications eligibility criteria and
required skills
in the end we'll take you through the
process of how to become a cloud
engineer
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your gcp related concepts
will have been cleared
i have a experience as your specialist
rahul with me for this training together
we'll walk you through the different
crucial azure keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
azure tutorial for big news
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss any updates from
simply learn what is azure what's the
big cloud service provider all about so
azure is a cloud computing platform
provided by microsoft now it's basically
an online portal through which you can
access and manage resources and services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data and
you can transform the data using
services that microsoft provides again
all you need is the internet and being
able to connect to the azure portal then
you get access to all of the resources
and their services in case you want to
know more about how it's different from
its rival which is aws i suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the aws versus your video so that you
can clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about this year it was
launched in february 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when aws was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like i
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through azure and one
of their most important selling points
is that 80 percent of fortune 500
companies use as your services which
means that most of the bigger companies
of the world actually recommend using
azure and then azure supports a wide
variety of programming languages the
c-sharp node.js java and so much more
another very important selling point of
zero is the amount of data centers it
has across the world now it's important
for a cloud service provider to have
many data centers around the world
because it means that they can provide
their services to a wider audience now
azure has 42 which is more than any
cloud service provider has at the moment
it expects to have 12 more in a period
of time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
his ear all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express
route now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
q storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and your virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored
customers who subscribe to azure get
access to all of the services
available through the azure interface
these services allow subscribers to
create cloud-based resources
such as virtual machines
and databases
azure comes with five different customer
support solutions from microsoft basic
developer standard professional direct
and premier
the scope and cost of these customer
assistance programs vary all azure
accounts get basic assistance for free
however microsoft charges a premium for
the other support options
developer support is 29 per month
100 per month for standard assistance
and one thousand dollar per month for
professional direct support
microsoft does not provide pricing
information for premier support
now that we have covered the basics of
microsoft azure let's dive down and
explore the services offered by azure
well
there are multiple services offered by
azure like machine learning analytics
containers compute databases developer
tools
devops hybrid and multi-cloud
identity
integration
internet of things
management
media migration mobile networking
security storage web and virtual desktop
but among these we will be discussing
only a few which are widely used by
organizations and individuals
around the world and we will be vividly
discussing these features in depth
and these services are compute
containers databases identity security
networking and storage
now let's start with the first one that
is
compute
azure compute is a service that allows
you to run cloud-based applications
on demand
disk cpus memory
networking and operating systems are
among the computing resources it
supplies
and the resources are on demand and can
be accessed in minutes
or even seconds you only pay for what
you use and for how long you use it
azure offers a variety of computing
solutions for development and testing
application deployment and data center
expansion
linux windows server sql server oracle
ibm and sap are all supported by the
servers the following are some of the
most well-known services azure virtual
machines virtual machine scale sets
azure container instances azure app
service
and azure functions or also serverless
computing
now let's discuss each of this one by
one
first is azure virtual machines
virtual machines are software based
computer simulations
a virtual processor memory storage and
networking resources are among the
resources available
virtual machines or vms run on operating
system and allow you to install and run
software much like a regular computer
you can use and operate the virtual
machine as if you were sitting in front
of it by utilizing a remote desktop
client
azure virtual machines allow you to
construct and operate
virtual machines in the cloud
infrastructure as a service is provided
through virtual machines
and they can be used in a variety of
ways
virtual machines are an excellent
solution when you need complete control
over an operating system
and its surroundings
all of the software running on the vm
can be customized
just as on a real machine
also
when you're running custom software or
hosting arrangements this capability
comes in handy
now coming on to the next one that is
virtual machine scale sets
scale sets are an azure compute resource
that may be used to deploy and manage a
group of identical virtual machines
virtual machine scale sets are meant to
provide real auto scale when all vms are
set up the same
virtual machines do not need to be
pre-provisioned as a result
developing large-scale services for big
computing big data and containerized
workloads is
easy more vm instances can be added as
demand grows
vm instances can be withdrawn when
demand decreases
the procedure might be human
automated or a hybrid of the two
now moving on to the next one that is
azure container instances
container instances are azure compute
resources for managing and deploying
containers
containers are virtualized
application
environments that are lightweight
they're built to be dynamically formed
scaled
and stopped
on a single host machine you can run
many instances of a containerized
application
then comes azure app services
you can create deploy and scale
enterprise grade web mobile and api apps
on any platform with azure app service
while employing a fully managed platform
to handle infrastructure maintenance you
can meet stringent performance
scalability
security and compliance requirements a
platform as a service solution is app
service
and following that we have azure
functions
when you simply care about the code that
runs your service and not the underlying
platform or infrastructure functions are
great
they are frequently used when you need
to respond to an event typically via
rest request
a timer or a message from another azure
service and the job can be accomplished
rapidly in seconds or less
now that we have completed all the
services offered by compute
let's proceed to the next one
that is
containers
containers are a type of virtualization
system
you can run several containers on a
single physical or virtual host in the
same way that you can run numerous
virtual machines on a single physical
host
unlike virtual machines you don't have
control over a container's operating
system
containers are lightweight and designed
to be built scaled out and stopped
dynamically whereas virtual machines
appear to be instance
of an operating system that you can
connect
to and administer
containers are built to help you to
react to changes on the go
containers allow you to swiftly resume
in the event of a crash of hardware
failure
docker is one of the most popular
container engines and azure supports it
containers offer these particular
servers
container instances
azure container services and container
registry
container instances
are the quickest and easiest method to
operate a container in the azure without
needing to manage virtual machines
or use any extra services
it's a power service that lets you
upload your containers
and have them run for you
moving on to the next one
are azure container services
azure container services or azure
kubernetes services allows users to
manage deploy and control operations of
kubernetes container
orchestration is a term used to describe
the process of automating managing and
interacting with a large number of
containers
azure kubernetes service is a
comprehensive container orchestration
service for distributed architectures
and high volumes of containers
and then comes container registry
a container registry is used to ease
container development by easing storage
and management of container images
now that we have covered containers and
the services offered let's move on to
the next azure service that is
databases
azure database is a fully managed
platform as a service database engine
that automates the majority of database
management tasks such as updating
patching backups and monitoring
microsoft has released a managed
instance aimed at on-premises clients so
if we have any sql databases on premises
that we want to migrate to azure without
any complex configuration or ambiguity
we can use manage instances the most
prominent services on the database
service are
azure cosmos db azure sql database
and azure post resql
now coming to the azure cosmos db
as your cosmos db is a multi-modal
globally distributed database service
you may increase throughput and storage
across any number of azure locations
around the world in an elastic and
independent manner
you can use any way of several common
apis to get single digit millisecond
data access
throughput latency availability and
consistency assurances are all covered
by azure cosmos db's service level
agreements
now azure cosmos db enables schema less
data allowing you to create extremely
responsive and always-on apps
that can handle constantly changing data
this functionality can be used to store
data that has been updated and
maintained by users all around the world
so next comes azure sql database
azure sql database is a relational
database based on the microsoft sql
server database engine's most recent
stable version
sql database is fast dependable
well-managed and secure database
you may use it to create data-driven
applications and websites in your
preferred programming language without
having to worry about infrastructure
what is azure active directory
but before getting into the definition
of azure ad let's have a real-life
example of azure ad to understand it in
a better way
there are a lot of pre-created
applications that you can offer
user access to using azure ad
so netflix is one of them so here's the
scenario
you want to share a netflix account with
a dozen people from your organization
giving your netflix username and
password to everyone isn't safe
so how do you give them access
your enters azure 80
the netflix application is available in
the azure ad gallery and can be added to
your azure ad tenant
this adds the application to your
tenancy and allows you to save your
netflix credentials in the secured
credential store
so that users can be assigned to it
the only people who have access are the
ones you give it to unless they have
their own account you're essentially
building a company
wide password vault then assigning
people to the systems
they require access to so they can log
in without
knowing the username and password for
those systems all they need is the azure
ad account or password and azure ad will
handle the rest
so saying in technical terms azure
active directory is a cloud-based
identity and access management
service from microsoft that allows your
employees to sign in and access
resources such as microsoft 365 the
azure portal and thousands of other sas
apps
and internal resources such as apps on
your company's intranet and network as
well as any cloud apps built by a
company
azure ad is required for sign in and
identity protection in microsoft online
business services such as microsoft 365
and azure
if you sign up for any microsoft online
business
you will be given access to azure ad
which includes all of the free services
but what makes azure ad so different
from windows 80 that it has become more
popular among people from technical firm
what is windows 80
active directory saves information about
network objects and make it easier for
administrator and users to find and use
their information
it organizes directory information
logically
and hierarchically using a structured
data store
but its supreme drawback is its layers
so let's have a look at its layers and
its functioning
first is adds
windows active directory domain services
active directory domain services is an
example of a directory service that
provides mechanisms for storing
directory data and making it available
to network users and administrators
second is adfs actor directory
federation services
federated identity and access management
is made possible by active directory
federation service
which securely shares digital identity
and entitlements right across security
and corporate boundaries to provide
customers partners and suppliers with a
streamlined user experience while
accessing an organization's web-based
applications
adfs extends the ability to employ
single sign-on capability accessible
within a single security or enterprise
boundary to internet pacing apps
third is
adrms active directory right management
services microsoft's active directory
rights management services safeguard
sensitive documents and emails unlike
traditional security methods like
firewalls and acls adrms encryption and
protection remain constant regardless of
where file goes or how it is transferred
but
azure active directory actually combine
these layers and make the whole process
more easier and hassle free
azure ed combines these layers into two
layers waad windows active azure
directory and windows azure access
control service
windows active azure directory combines
all the problems revolving around
identification management
and windows azure access control service
takes care of federating all the
services of an organization
so let's have an example when an
employee joined the premises of an
organization the administrator guides
them towards signing to particular
services they use and then give access
to it and the employees can access these
services through their credentials like
username and password
now that we know what is azure active
directory and how it functions different
from adds let's have a look at the
service audience of azure active
directory
azure ad is majorly intended to rfp
admins app developers and online
subscribers
for it admins you can use azure ad as an
it administrator to limit access to your
apps and app resources based on your
business needs
when accessing critical organizational
resources for example you can utilize
azure ad to enforce multi-factor
authentication
finally azure active directory provides
you with strong features to help you
protect users identities and credentials
while also meeting your access
governance requirements as an app
developer you may utilize azure ad to
add single sign-on to your app using a
standard based method allowing it to
function with the user's existing
credentials
also azure ad
has apis that may be used to create
customized app experiences based on
existing organizational data
for online subscribers
you're already using
azure area as a subscriber
each tenant of microsoft 365 office 365
azure and dynamic crm online is an azure
ad 10 and by default
you may begin managing access to your
connected cloud apps right away
so now that we know the basic concept of
azure ada let's have a quick demo of it
so the first thing we need to do is log
in in our azure id account
and then go to azure active directory
sector here you will see add option
where you can
add a user group enterprise application
app registration according to your
choice
and below that
you can search for any intent like for
user
or for any group
so right now it doesn't belongs to any
group
or there is no user
with this name
here you will get basic information
like their name what is their id
what is the license
which groups they belong
and what are the devices they use you
can also have an access to
their password as well so without doing
any further delay let's start with the
video
so what is azure machine learning
azure machine learning is a cloud
solution that helps you speed up and
manage your machine learning projects it
can be used by machine learning
specialists data scientists and
engineers in their daily workflows
models are trained and deployed and
mlops are managed
you can use an open source platform like
pytorch tensorflow or scikit-learn to
build a model or use one created in
azure machine learning
model monitoring retraining and
redeployment are all made easier using
these tools
but this brings us to a question
that who exactly machine learning is for
so individuals and teams deploying mlops
inside their company can use azure
machine learning to move machine
learning models into production in a
safe and auditable environment
data scientists and machine learning
experts will find tools to help them
speed up and automate their daily tasks
tools for embedding models into
applications or services will be
available to application developers
platform developers will find a strong
set of tools for constructing advanced
ml technology
underpinned by resilient is as resource
manager apis
now that we know the basics of azure ml
let's have a look at its infrastructure
readiness and security
so azure machine learning is an azure
cloud platform that adds security
to machine learning projects
so integrations for security include the
following
network security groups in azure virtual
networks
azure keyword is a world where you may
store security secrets like storage
account access details
and set up an azure container registry
behind the v-net
so now let's dive down deep and explore
its project workflow
models are usually created as part of
project with a specific goal and
objective
multiple people are usually involved in
these projects iterative development is
used while experimenting with data
algorithms
and models
now coming to the project life cycle
while the project lifespan will differ
depending on the project it will
typically look like this
a workspeak space organizes a project
and facilitate collaboration among
multiple users who are all working
toward the same goal
users in a workspace may easily share
the result of the experiments through
the studio user interface
or they can use versioned assets for
jobs like environments and storage
references
so users work can be automated in a
machine learning pipeline and activated
on a timetable or https request when a
project is ready for operation
therefore
models can be deployed to the manage
interferencing
solution in real time or batch
abstracting away the infrastructure
management that is traditionally
necessary for model deployment
now let's proceed further and understand
the concept of mlops that is
devops for machine learning
mlops or devops for machine learning is
a process for generating models for
production use
if not
reproducible the lifetime of a model
from training to deployment must be
auditable
mlops or machine learning operations is
based on devops principles and methods
to improve workflow efficiency
continuous integration delivery and
deployment for example
these ideas are applied to the machine
learning process by mlops with the
purpose of experimentation and model
deployment can be done more quickly and
quality assurance and end-to-end line
edge tracking are more efficient ways to
put models into production
now
let's explore what is azure ml studio
so azure machine learning studio is an
online service that includes low code
and no code alternators for project
development and asset management in
azure machine learning
basically it is a workspace where you
can create build train the machine
learning models
for an inclusive data science platform
the studio integrates no code and no
code first experience
so now that we have covered all the
important concepts of azure machine
learning
let's have a demo for a better
understanding of how machine learning is
used in azure
so let's start with the demo first you
need to browse the link studio.azure
ml.net and here you need to login with
your azure account
so once you have logged in you will be
led to a new window this is new window
here you can see a few options
so
let's start
and see one by one what these options
are
so the first one is projects
basically this gives you a list of all
the experiments that you have already
worked on so here you can see we haven't
worked on any experiment yet
then comes experiment
experiments are all the programs and
codes that you have worked on to create
it or deploy a model that you've just
created for an experiment
so as i said we haven't created any
experiment yet so the list is
now over here
when you click on samples you can see a
few
sample experiments provided to you by
azure
portal by default
and
following that we have web services
so we all know since azure is a cloud
computing platform so all the data
gathered from our experiments needs to
be uploaded to the cloud
so web services gives you a list of all
the experiments that you have in the
cloud so you can access them from
anywhere
so
when you create an experiment and work
on it when you add it to the cloud the
data is stored here
so then comes data sets
it gives you all the data sets you have
in your azure portal when you click on
the samples option
again you can see all this data sets
provided to you
by default in your azure portal
then comes train models
so while working on an experiment you
will come across a point where you need
to train your model
so basically this gives you a list of
all the models that you have trained in
experiments or azure programs
and in the last come settings
any changes that you want to make to
your workspace is done under settings
here you can see
this is your workspace name workspace
description which is by default
and all the details is provided
here only so whatever changes you want
to make your workspace you will be doing
this over here
so now let's start with the demo
so down below you can see the add or new
option here
so click on it
and then you can see there are a few
weight uh templates provided by you
provided to you by azure itself so we'll
click on blank experiment
once you click on the blank experiments
you'll be guided to a new experiment
window
so this is the new window and this
window is divided into three parts
these are the components
where you will plan your model
this is the canvas to design your model
and then the properties of the model
in the component section you can see
samples already present there so you can
select any one of them according to your
requirement
so here when i'm typing samples
i'll work on airport quotes datasets so
i just need to drag this option over
here
but before starting
with our experiment let's change the
name
so here i'm changing it to
airport
codes
demo model
so now you can see the name of the
experiment is changed
now when you click on it
and
select visualize
just a second
you can see the number of rows and
columns provided to it the data is which
is required
for its data set to be created and for
its model to be created
so the four rows four columns are
airport id city state and name
now
we will move towards the part where we
define field we need to make our
predictions for
so type columns in the search
bar
uh under manipulation
section
you can
see there are multiple options provided
to you
so here we will select
select columns and data sets
as we are working on data sets
now connect your data set with this
option
so you can see a red alert over here
so
when you click on
it you can see it is asking for values
in your data set so to add values
click on the launch column selector
under properties
section
so once you click on it here you need to
select all the options
needed per required values so for my
experiment model i need all these data
sets so i'll add
all of these and then click on the save
option
so let me just add this
now i have saved
all the
values i need in our in my data set
so now
you can see the alert is
gone
so now we have the data sets that we
want to work on so let's look for an
appropriate algorithm for it
so
while looking into the classification
algorithm
we
know that our
so here you can see it under
classification model we have
these options
so we know that a target value is
divided into two classifications so the
algorithm we will be using
is a
two class
so we will be using two class booster
decision tree
because it calculates the accuracy for
every mode and once the calculated
accuracy is more than a required
accuracy then only it moves to the next
node
so basically this gives you a prediction
value close to the accurate value of the
model so we will just drag this option
over here
so now the next step we have is to train
our model
so we just need to type train over here
and select train model option
so
just
drag it to the canvas
now connect the two booster decision
tree
to the train model
now you can again see the red a lot for
a
required
data as it doesn't have any data to work
on so our next step is to split the data
so
we'll type split
and drag display data option on our
canvas
as you can see this is also
saying uh
it needs an input port data set so we'll
connect a data set
with it
so
that it is provided with the data
so when you click on it you can see it
it is asking for a split percentage
so
you split the data into training and
testing where 80 goes to training and 20
to testing so we will mention 0.08 over
here
and
so now we will just connect the 80 data
to the train model
as we said the 80 goes for training
but you can still see the alert in the
train model because it is not aware of
the column it needs to train on
so we will click on
launch column selector
now you just need to select all the
columns
you need to work on so i'm selecting the
airport id number
now you can see once i save it
that the alert is gone
now our next step is to find the score
of a model so let's type score
in our search bar
and drag the score model over
here
let me just reduce the size of the
canvas yeah
so we will just connect our train model
to the score model
so
again you will see the red alert as it
doesn't know the data it needs to test
on so for that we will connect the
remaining testing data in the split data
option to the
score model
now you can see the alert option is gone
now coming to the final step that is
evaluation of the model so let's type
evaluation
and here you can see the evaluate model
option we just need to drag it to the
canvas
so
let's
connect it with our score model
now your model for the app port code
data set is complete so this is the
whole
model
now you need to save the model and then
click on run option
so here i have saved it
and
you can see it's running
you can see the model running and going
through every node
as you can see the green mark
as it's verifying through every node
so once it's done click on evaluate
model
and
then click on visualize
now you can see the accuracy is a
98
here you can see the accuracy is 98
which is almost the prediction value now
you can see the positive and negative
labels as well
so this whole data is known as confusion
matrix
now for the values close to the pos
positive label it gives me the number of
true predictions
that uh the number of data i'll provide
it will it shows that 72 predictions
will be right and one will be
wrong
now let's go back and
[Music]
run this model over the web
so by clicking on a setup web service we
will click on predictive web service
now we will just connect
web service input to the score model
so that once the program is uploaded to
the cloud it is directly connected to
the score model
and gives us the
output
so now you need to save this
and run
this will execute the entire model
now
all
we are
left with is deploying the model
now
you just need to click
on deploy web service
so then you will see you will be taken
to a new window
here you can
see
the response page where it's showing
test option you need to click on it
so here you can see a new window has
popped up so you just need to mention
the details like for city i am
mentioning bangalore
for state i am mentioning bernardika
and name of the airport is
international
airport
and i just need to save this data
so now down below you can see it gives
me predictive values
and this is the airport id
for my mentioned details
so the accuracy of this id will be 0.98
which is 98
which is almost accurate to the 100
percent
so this was our experiment and this is
how we can use ml in azure thank you
now let's consider a scenario so here we
have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other and they
say that the data that they're
generating from their applications or
products is increasing exponentially now
considering that this data is coming
from a number of different products
it'll be a bit of a task to analyze and
store all of this data so he wonders how
they're going to manage that his friend
suggests that they use azure's data
factory now what does azure's data
factory actually do first it stores data
with the help of the data link storage
now any kind of data can be stored in
the data lake storage then you can
analyze the data you can transform the
data with the help of pipelines and you
can publish the organized data you can
visualize the data with third-party
applications like apache spark or hadoop
as well now what exactly is data factory
so now let's have a look at what exactly
is data factory now data factory falls
under the identity domain of services in
the azure catalog and is a cloud-based
integration service basically what it
does is it works on your data it stores
your data it orchestrates and automates
the movement or transformation of data
it works heavily on the data that you
store now let's see how it actually
works or how the flow of its processes
are firstly we have the input data set
which is nothing but the data that you
have within your data store the one that
you need processed then you pass this
data through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures are hype now after
this is done you get an output dataset
now this output dataset will contain
data that is in a structured form
because it's already been transformed
and made structured in the pipeline
stage then it is given into linked
services like azure data lake block
storage or sql now what it does is these
store information that is very important
when it comes to connecting to an
external source now this is you know if
you wanted an example you know how in an
sql server you need to mention the
source and destination of your data now
for example consider an sql server so
you need a connection string so that you
can connect to an external device you
need to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
link services work and finally you need
a gateway now a gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like apache spark r
hadoop and so on so all this time i've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to azure
data factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
frameworks which is external frameworks
like hadoop apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the azure
data lake store and then it is provided
to external frameworks like r apache and
spark so that they can be worked on now
there are two main concepts when it
comes to data lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the correct the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the azure data factory
to move data from an sql database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on google it's called you just need
to google it ssms the first link you can
take here
and there you have it so you just need
to click here and download the file so
we i've already downloaded the file so
basically this is used to create a
database which we'll be transferring to
the blob storage so this will take about
depending on your computer speed pretty
long or little to no time i've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes and
finally once the installation is done
here's what we're going to do we should
go into the dashboard of microsoft azure
we need to create a data warehouse so
we'll go into all resources create a
source
go to database
and select sql data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so i've already set
up a possible set of names
youtube
it's free trial the source is already
created
a blank database the server we need to
create a new one so
that we'll name it as youtube server
youtube
admin as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done
and here we need to change how much you
want the lowest i mean how much
computation you want how much the
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and great
so now we're creating an sql data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and go to the resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which i've already opened here and then
go here
and copy this paste it here seo
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is admin
youtube admin and the password which is
also given there
right go to options we go to the
database name which is youtube
everything else is there
we need to change it to tcp ip
and connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
and we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier you go to databases and
here you have the youtube database that
we just created right click this and add
a new query
i already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name clark kent and last name is
bruce main and the table that's created
will have these two rows so now we're
going to execute this
there you have it two rows have been
affected so now let's have a look at our
table
um
execute this line
and there you go the table's here so now
that this is done we're going back into
azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the storage
where the blob storage is going to
happen so we're going to storage
accounts and click on add
so here it's a free trial resource group
is youtube
storage account name is
the
store
that's all
okay yes performance is standard
general purpose
you can do locally since we don't need
to be very reliable at least for this
one advance this fine
view and create
that's done and we create
now we'll wait for the deployment to
finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
blob
which does not exist and okay
it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data factory now so
we go to
all services
and search for data factory
we press add
so here we
free trial use existing
which we have youtube each yes and
create so now we've created a new data
factory now we'll wait while it's being
deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
we'll name it
our description run once now
onto now okay
all right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so
so what you need to do is select a
secure as your sql data warehouse so
once again go to previous
here we select azure skill data
warehouse go here
search for
source
which is your subscription free trial
here youtube server
and the databases youtube you also need
to provide your username and password
i've saved it here
youtube admin
[Music]
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab
next
next
and now for our destination so where are
we going to connect this to we're going
to azure blob storage next
destination
job subscription free trial
and simply start
now we need to name our
name our storage path
next
all of this can be
passed on
so
here's what we're doing it copying
whatever is inside this to the azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the
here's a visual representation of what's
happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
and let's have a look if it's actually
worked out
go to our database we'll go into storage
accounts simply store
go to blobs
you've created a new one
and there you have it
so based on the container that you've
named there it's created a new one here
so actually i earlier created the name
called simply blob but as you can see
here as long as you name a container it
will create a folder inside which you'll
find your particular thing that you
copied and that's it you've copied data
similarly you can do a number of
multiple operations on this container on
the on the pipeline you just created
with the data factory and that's that
and with that we've reached the end of
another video i hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more so
first of all let's look into why is
azure virtual network important
so why azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity
time consuming process and building
network topologies
could not divert network traffic to its
destination on time so these were a
couple of challenges the company was
facing so
the employees thought that what could be
the possible solution to these
challenges
and then we require the azure virtual
network in that case
so first of all let's understand what is
azure virtual network is
an azure vnet or a virtual network
represents your network or environment
to run vms and applications in the
cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
internet so virtual network you can
consider it as a virtual cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud space
virtually assigned
to the users or or to the organization
which they can dedicatedly use for their
purpose
so for example if you have to create
some
instances or virtual machines onto the
azure cloud
and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example
then you might require the virtual
network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual network require the
range of ip addresses that you want to
allocate to them and that is something
you can customize using the azure
virtual network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed
to your instances in the virtual network
how the firewall securities should be
applied
everything the end user can control in
the virtual network so it seems like
that you are working in your own data
center ideally you would be working on
to the azure cloud using the virtual
network
now what are the advantages of using the
azure virtual network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as i said that
it feels like it seems like that you are
working in your on-prem environment that
means within your data center but
ideally it is a virtual space that is
allocated to you
which is a kind of an isolated
environment and that is specifically
designed for your tasks and the
activities
a generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
network which can access
the public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is enabled in
the virtual net so that a subnet which
will be created in the vnet can be
accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control list defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented high network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the azure
network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated network
topologies in a simple
manner and which is easily manageable as
well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual network
one of them is the subnets
then you have routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the
major or a prime important component in
the virtual network so what you have to
do is first obviously you would be
creating a virtual network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning
virtual partitioning inside the
virtual network
subnet lets user segment the virtual
network into one or more
sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every department there
should be
some set of ip addresses that you want
to allocate to
the machines that the employees are
using
or
all the department should be isolated
that means they should have their own
network ids
and the network addresses allocated to
their machines
and in that case what you would do is
you would create the subnets and the
subnet ids that would be allocated to
those departments
these sub networks can be separated
logically and each subnet consists of a
server so what you do is when you create
a subnet you can you can create a server
or an instance inside that subnet and
how do you want to give an access to
that instance depends on
criteria or the requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on
how the public subnet should be
interacting with the internet and for
the private subnet as the name suggests
that the internet is blocked so that
means it is completely isolated in the
virtual network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the nat gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggests public instances that public
subnets that means
they have the direct internet
connectivity
next component is routing and
the routing is primarily a routing rules
you can say that are applied
and those are actually applied to
the routers only so since on the cloud
we cannot have a direct router access
and hence using the routing as a
component we can define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router and the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet azure virtual network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
network
automatically a route table is created
and that
basically is required to route the
traffic
and that can be used by every subnet
that doesn't mean that you only have to
create a single route table in the
virtual network you can have multiple
route tables also created which can be
associated with different subnets as
well then you have the network security
groups
it is kind of a firewall that protects
the virtual machine by limiting the
network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
network traffic depending upon the
destination ipa transport
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances
and
or virtual machines and
they basically
define that how the traffic should be
reaching to the ports onto the virtual
machine so how do you want to open up
the ports and for which ip addresses you
want to open up the ports that is
something the end user or the
administrator has to
specify our design so they act as a kind
of a firewall rules only that protects
the virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
vnet
so first of all you have to create a
virtual network so virtual network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual network then you would be
creating
subnets which are considered as a subset
within the virtual network
so cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first vnets are created then
the subnets are created and then you
configure the properties in the security
group have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual network in the azure
cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual network so you can
create one as a public subnet the other
one as a private subnet for example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual network
for which virtual network you're
creating an instance within that virtual
network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created
and then connect instance to a relevant
network security group so attach your
network security group to the instances
and based on the properties or the rules
that are defined in the network security
group that will be applied to the
instances within the subnets finally
configure the properties in the network
security and set the policies
as a result you will be able to launch
your instance on azure within
the virtual network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create azure virtual network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there
to watch our demo on
the azure virtual network in today's
session i would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on microsoft azure and here you can see
on my screen that i have already logged
in into
the azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual network you can
type
and search in the dashboard
in the search bar
with respect to the virtual networks
and here you can find
uh the virtual network and the gateways
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on the virtual networks and
then it will give you the options
to add the components inside the virtual
networks
so let me first
open up
the virtual network
right now
in theory we discussed that the virtual
network comprises of multiple components
and sub components so primarily is that
first you have to create a virtual
network
then you have to assign the ipv4 cidr
block to the virtual network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual network along with that you
define the routing rules
and
likewise you create
the instances inside the subnets that
will be part of the virtual networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so i would be adding up a new
virtual network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
v-net which is by default so when you
created the azure credentials
the demo virtual network was already
created by the azure so that it can
provide you the
default settings
and then the test one has been created
by me and that's the customized one or
you can say a non-default virtual
network
so i'll i'm going to add another
v-net and
would define
the name to it
so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
group so
what is a resource group it is primarily
a collection of resources that share the
same life cycle permissions and the
policies so if you have a resource group
created you can use it otherwise you can
create a new resource group so i already
have one
that is the demo one i would be using
that
in the instance details you have to
specify the name of the virtual network
so
these are certain
parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say i
put something like
test
vnet
as the virtual network that i want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created
so these are the available regions that
you can select i would go with
us east
east us only and then we have to define
the ip addresses also
see so in the ip addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed ip
address for that vnet
so what you can do is you can specify a
range of ip addresses now whenever we
talk about a virtual network and the ip
addresses we primarily focus on the
private ips only so this is the private
ip that we are actually
talking about so i can reserve some
ip address cidr
for our vnet and that is the range of
40.0.0.0 16.
i'm going to reserve so now we'll create
one subnet and
we'll name that subnet so as we
discussed that subnets are the sub
components of
the vnet
so here you can see we have already
created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and let's name it to something like uh
demo subnet right and the subnet should
have the ip address range and that ip
address range should be part of the
v-net only did inviting
so same subnet address range you would
be defining in the subnet as well so
that will be 40.0.1.
or we can select 2.0
24.
the rest of the things would be default
we are not attaching any route table as
of now so just click on ok
and here you can see
that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we'll go
to the search bar
and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test vnet and
inside the demo subnet
so that our virtual machine gets the
private ip address from
the subnet that has been created in the
vnet itself so what you need to do is
you have to open up the virtual machines
click on add
and here you should add a new virtual
machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and
the network details
where we would be defining
the v-net as well as the subnet where
the virtual machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name
something like
test
vm
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking
we would be selecting
the test v-net as
our virtual network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet
so that is the recently one added in the
test v-net and we want that our virtual
machine should be part of that subnet
only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public ip also
assigned since from the public network
we need to access those virtual machines
so we will keep it enabled right and the
next
would be the default settings that we
are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and
then create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
v-net and it gets
the private ip address from the subnet
that has been part of the
v-net uh which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine so let's
wait for a couple of more minutes and
we'll look into the status of the main
now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that a virtual
machine is created in a correct
subnet or not and that is something
which we can validate
by checking the private ip address so it
got the private ip from the range of
the ip address that we have specified in
the subnet
now in order to access this particular
virtual machine you have to use the
public ip since
since we have to access it from the
internet so
from the private ip this virtual machine
will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public ip address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
the virtual network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub-components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other
and that actually creates a kind of an
isolated environment on the public cloud
which gives you
the understanding that you can work into
just like an on-prem environment first
we will understand what is azure devops
followed by features of azure devops
then we will dive into and explore azure
develop services followed by azure
devops server and then we will look into
the azure develop services and azure
develop server differences and at last
we will explore azure develops labs with
proper demonstration
so let's get started
so what is azure devops azure devops
enables teams to organize work
collaborate on code development and
build and deploy applications using
developer services
azure develops the culture and set of
protocols that brings together
developers project managers and
contributors to collaborate on software
development it enables businesses to
create and enhance products more quickly
than they could with additional software
development methods
you can use azure devops services in the
cloud or azure develop server on
premises
azure devops has built-in functionality
that you may access via a web browser or
an ide client depending on your business
needs you can use one or more of the
following standard owned services
azure repos azure develops a built-in
functionality so for source management
of your code azure repos
offer git repositories or team
foundation version control
azure pipelines build and release
services provided by azure pipelines to
assess continuous integration and
delivery of your applications
azure boards
using kanban and scrum methodologies
azure boards provides a set of agile
tools for planning and tracking for code
bugs and issues
as your test plans manual and
exploratory testing and continuous
testing are among the options available
in azure test plans for testing your
applications
and at last ask your artifacts this
allows teams to share packages from
public and private sources including
marvin npm nuget and more and
incorporate package sharing into their
pipelines so this brings us to the
features of devops
first we have is dashboard control you
can rapidly navigate to different
regions of the project build and manage
dashboards and set dashboard widgets
using the devops dashboard functionality
then we have improved source control git
and team foundation version control a
centralized client server system which
are two prominent methods of source
control supported by azure develop
solution to observe change history you
can add and manage azure git tags
reviews downloads and modify files
following that we have planned and
tracked your work you can utilize azure
devops systems to track features
requirements user stories tasks issues
and more using a variety of work items
then we have integrated collaboration
servers the tool that allows teams to
collaborate throughout the whole azure
develops feature set including team
dashboards project wiki discussion
within work item forms and many others
then we have support for exploratory
testing manual exploratory and
continuous testing are made easier with
azure develop which include workflow
customization end-to-end traceability
criteria-based selection and real-time
visualization that show the test
activities and at last comes continuous
integration and deployment many
developers use ci cd and azure devops
makes it so easy to do so developers may
automate various design activities with
azure pipelines including defining and
building association steps writing test
instructions and managing simultaneous
releases
well this brings us to azure develop
services
you get an integrated set of services
and tools with azure develops to manage
your software project from planning to
development to testing and deployment a
client or server model is used to
deliver these services many of them are
offered via a user friendly web
interface that works with all major
browsers the source control build
pipelines and work tracking are just a
few of the services that may be managed
through a client you can see the left
pane is where you access azure develop
services as demonstrated in the figure
below so now that we have covered azure
develop services
let's move on to azure devops server
version control reporting requirements
management project management automated
bills testing and release management are
all capabilities of azure develop server
a microsoft product it provides devops
features and spans the complete
application cycle so now that we know
what azure develop services and azure
developer server are so let's have a
crisp comparison between them to know
how exactly they differ from each other
despite the fact that azure develop
service is a hosted version of azure
develop server there are several
features that differ some functions of
azure developer server aren't available
in azure develop services
so when deciding which platform to use
or considering a transition from
on-premises to the cloud keep the
following points in mind cope and scale
data authentication users and groups and
manage user access so first is scope and
scale data azure develop services and
azure develop server are slightly
different
organizations and projects are currently
the only alternatives for scoping and
scaling data azure developer services
organization get their own urls and
always have exactly one project
collection whereas deployment project
collection and projects are the three
methods for scoping and scaling data in
azure develop server then we have
authentication to connect to azure
develop services using the public
internet depending on your
organization's arrangement you can use
microsoft account credentials or azure
ad credentials to login you can also
configure azure ad to require
multi-factor authentication ip address
restrictions and other security features
but you connect to an intranet serving
using azure develop server windows
authentication and active directory
domain credentials are used to log in so
this method is completely open and you
will never be asked to sign in next we
have users and group you may use a
similar technique to grant access to
groups of users and azure developed
services azure ad groups can be added to
azure develop services group so you must
add users one at a time if you utilize
microsoft account instead of azure ad on
the other hand by adding active
directory groups to multiple azure
developer groups you make grant user
access to deployment in azure develop
server the membership of ad groups are
kept in sync so users gain and lose
access to azure devops server as they
are added and withdrawn in ed and at
last there is manage user access you
manage access to features in azure
devops and azure develop server by
signing users to an access level each
user in your azure develop services
organization
must be assigned an access level as
usual as visual studio subscriber sign
in azure develop services verifies them
so without a visual studio subscription
you can give basic access to five users
for free whereas all use of azure
developer server is on the honor system
specify the access levels on the
administrative administration page to
set access levels for users based on
their license and assign unlicensed user
stakeholder access only so now that we
have covered all the important features
and concepts of azure develop now let's
move on to the next very important
aspect of azure develop which is azure
devops lab
the azure develop lab is a place where
you can learn about software development
and operations with azure develop
services you can simplify and speed up
the devops process it explains how to
use azure develop services to automate
software delivery and satisfy business
requirements so to understand it in a
better way let's have a demo of azure
devops lab so let's start with our azure
develops demo so first what we need to
do is navigate to this
website
ashore.microsoft.in or we can directly
uh login through
dev.azure.com also so first what we need
to do is sign into a microsoft azure
account
so
after
signing in
you'll be led to this page
you just need to click on continue
and here what you need to do is create
an
organization under which you're gonna
create your projects
multiple projects and you're gonna
attach your team members to it or group
members to it and you want to get the
access
to your projects
so what is the difference between
organization and project is
if you have given anybody access to your
organization or somebody is a part of
the organization then
then that particular individual will
have access to all of your projects but
if you have given somebody only access
to your project then you'll be only
restricted to that particular project
you won't be able to access any other
project that is present under that
particular organization
that you both are part of so basically
organization is something that is used
to connect to groups of or related
projects or somebody who is already a
part of a particular organization so
here we will give it a name so i am
giving a simply
demo
as the organization name
and here you can see that the projects
under this organization will be hosted
under the south india
region
and we need to enter the capture
and click on continue
just a second
so now you can see this saying that it
is taking you to an organization
okay so we already have an organization
of the same name so let's just change it
to something else
let's give it
simply demo
a large
so here you can see that i see this
saying that it's taken to your azure
devops organization where you'll be
creating your projects
so now you can see
your organization name
here
and here you just need to create the
project name so i'm giving it a
simply
demo
project
now below you can see
visibility we can opt either public or
private so what is public or private so
basically
if
you keep it keep the project of
keep the visibility of the project
public
then
once you copy this
url
so
as i was saying once you copy this url
into some other browser or incognito
mode
you will be able to have the access to
the project
but if you keep its visibility private
then only the people who have real
access to your organization or to your
project will be able to access that
project or will be able to see that
project or work on it
as you can see uh public projects are
disabled for our organization so
we can't
select public
so we'll go for private
and click on create project
now here
you can see
the home page of your organization where
you have
this project
and here you can access the statistics
of project how it is performing how much
time you have contributed to it or what
all services you have added to your
project
and down below you will be able to see
that there is just one member which is
the
root user of this project
and
once you start adding more members to
your project it will their details will
be
added to this particular
block so
now here you can see
these are the services boards reports
pipelines test plans
and artifacts services that is
provided to you to add to your project
so now let's have a
look
at them one by one
so first one is boards
as we click on boards you can see
multiple options
your work items boards backlogs sprints
queries delivery plans
here you can see this all empty as we
haven't added any service or we haven't
worked on our project yet
so let's just click on
new work item
so here you can see one is epic issue
and task
so epic is an option that is uh
you can see a pro
option
for work items
so basically epic represents the
business initiator to be complete and it
is basically available for basic agile
scrum and cmmi process templates
so what it exactly does is increases
customer engagement that whoever
whatever your project is if it's
the engagement
of your project that how it's performing
and how it is performing towards
the people
whom you have given access to the
project also helps to
create new architecture to improve the
performance of your project
and
it also support mobile application so
basically when you're deploying any
mobile application in your project or
creating a mobile application as a
project so it will be able to
support that as well
let's click on it
so here you can see you need to
enter a title for your
epic option
so here you need to add the title of
your effect like
for say
we are creating a healthcare or an
e-commerce application so obviously it
will be segmented into different parts
like you'll be having search options or
support options
or home page so we just need to give
it a name
and here you can see its state is to do
for now we just have to do because we
haven't
actually created anything in our project
and we haven't given any input
so it's a to-do list and
once we start working on it it gets we
can change the state it
can be in progress or completing
so there are multiple states for your
epic
and here you can see the area is simply
demo project that means that we want to
assign
this
search you know epic into this project
and we can also click description over
here that what exactly our new epic is
about like for search options we need to
specify or give a description that
you know this is for searching options
related to our application like for
healthcare one can type for
medicines
or
doctors
or sloths
so
that is
that that is thing that we can add in a
description
that it will help the user to understand
what this feature is about
so this was epic and
once done we can click on save
so here you can see other
stuffs also like priority
so we can select priority according to
our
will
so here by default it is priority two
so friday basically is
which function will come first
and here you can mention start date
target date
so once it's done you can click on save
now let's move
to the next one
second what we have is issue
so basically issues are
for you to that's your work
and the
epics are used to
track the group work and the large
scenarios
but
this is
track like like we sort of project
statistics so it will help you to
understand the individual progress
so basically issues are raised when
you
find any obstacle in your
progress or in your work so it can be
compared to impediments also so when
you're working with agile or
you need to deal with issues so by
default we have agile
to our project assign
so
like for example we can see that uh
we have a meeting so during the meeting
members report if they have encountered
any bug or any any impairments
so
what next we have to do is we have to
track them and resolve it so these are
the issues that can uh
one can find
like possibilities
so you can assign here
and give it a description again
and just save it so
once a user faces these issues
we can keep a track of it
and
once it is raised we can resolve it
coming to the
next one
next we have is
task so by the name only we can uh
well understand what task is
so a task is a smaller item or a
smaller segment to track activity that
contains all the information needed to
accomplish a part of
an issue
or you can say user story requirements
so this option is available for basic
agile scrum and cmmi process templates
so again we can give it a name
what task we want to assign
and give it a description
and according to that we can
select the priority
and save it
so the task will be added to your
project
we are not
assigning any task right now because as
i said we haven't added any uh
particular
project or particular details or
application or we haven't deployed any
application yet in our project
so
that is why we are not adding anything
over here again
because first we need to understand what
these services are and what these
services are used for
next we have back lots
so
backlogs helps you
to understand the flow of your problem
like today you have contributed 10
of
your time and
you have completed the 10 of the work or
you have worked on certain segments of
the project like or
say
you have worked in the support area
so
it helps you
to
understand and keep the track of the
flow of your project how it is
performing and how it is developing and
how it is built every day
next we have a strength
so sprints are basically a time box
interval that supports your team's
ability
to work using the agile processes and
tools so what you can do is whether
you're having let's say you're having a
healthcare application so you just
need to
have a segment of it and drop it over
here
so what would what it will do is it will
get the attention of all the team
members so basically what it does it it
makes your project more manageable
it uh increases the quality of your
project and also makes it work even more
faster and more frequently once you add
the segment to the sprint
so you can see it in one way it gets to
priority and people need to work on it
and it gives your project more
flexibility to adapt to change
now now sometimes what happens is many
associates scrum sprints
with agile software development
so
sometimes
are often thought to be the same thing
coming to the next one we have queries
so the query page basically remembers
the view you have
last navigated
and when you log in again or when you
come back again
to the same portal it returns you to
that very particular view only
so it can
you can say that it runs with azure
develops command line interface
and
all the
open
like all the pages that you have gone
through you can
keep a track of it over here
you just need to click over here all and
you can just see all the queries you
have
defined
in all this while and
also you can share the queries with the
team members
so they can also know that where you
have been working lately
or which segment you have been working
on
or what was the last navigation
which you have been going through in
this whole project
so it can help you manage your project
in a more efficient way
and keep a track of
how
and what all segments you have been
working on and what are the segments you
need to work on in your project
coming to the next one we have delivery
plans
so here you can see uh we haven't
created any plan yet so basically
delivery plans are a calendar view of
multiple
teams or team backlogs or individual
backlogs from different projects
so basically it replaces the delivery
plans marketplace extension
and it is only available for azure
develop services
so here you can
you can you can say it's a summary or
a time summary of all the projects you
have been working on in a particular
organization
so now that we have covered both uh
let's
move to the next one which is
repose
so with the name itself we can uh well
understand that repo stands for
repositories
so basically it is a set of repositories
that allows you to control and manage
your project code like for say you're
deploying a healthcare application so
these
repos options
help you create repositories and
manage your code of that particular
application and more efficient way
so what you can do is you can connect
project solutions by using the repos
link
uh as you can see here it is shown
so let's uh look into its option one by
one first we have
files
so in files your project solution will
be available in this section
so
repositories can create manage and
import those solutions
okay
so you just need to upload your
solutions
of
your code or your project
here and
it will
just create repositories for it
and it will help you create manage those
solutions in a better way
you can see these uh
clone to your computer push an existing
repository from command line and import
repositories if you want to
import any uh solution
like here you can just
click on import and add the solution to
a depository
so
this is what files
do
basically you can see it say uh it is a
it's like a physical folder itself where
you have all your
mini files or repositories or solutions
you can say of
data so basically it's it functions like
a
physical folder itself
so it helps you keep a track of
your codes and
everything
next comes is comments
so uh
in commit section you can manage commit
history
for your repositories that you have
created in files
so it just commits those repositories
with author details from branches like
for say we have a team
one from
spot branch and
one from management branch
so
whoever creates that repositories and
have the solution
it commits that repositories under that
under that particular member of the team
with the branch name
then comes pushes
so push histories are available in this
section
from each pull request done by the
developers developers per se the team
members who have been working on this
particular project and creating
repositories and solutions
so what is full request
so full requests or prs are a way to
change or review of merge
code in our repositories
so
basically team uses these pr's to review
code and get feedbacks or changes
whether like
for say you are deploying a code or a
solution
so one can review them what all changes
needs to be made or what all application
needs to be made or whether the code is
already fine or not
so basically teams use these prs to
review the solutions and codes storing
these repositories
or
you can merge multiple solutions or
multiple codes into the main branch
basically the viewers can step through
the proposed changes and leave those
comments
and what to approve or reject that
particular code
or you can say to upgrade or what all
changes we want to make it they vote for
it that whether that needs to be made to
that particular solution or not
so these are the prs
next we have branches so
we can manage multiple branching
information in this particular section
you can create create or release
branches
from master to death
okay so all users
can actually
can actually
create or release branches from
branching information available in this
particular section
next come
tags
so
tags are the
used to point out specific comments
like uh
giving message tags and data information
to branches you can create your name in
conventions to branches by using commit
tags
and
the second the next one is full request
which we have already discussed
the pr's
that are basically
in pushes
so now we have commit
completed repose also
so let's move on to the next one which
is
pipelines
so here you can see see that we don't
have any pi pipeline
created for us yet so let's have a look
at the
provided options one by one
the first one is environments
so basically it is a collection of
resources where you are actually deploy
your application that you are working on
so it can
you can say it contains one or more
virtual machines containers web apps etc
whatever
resources you have actually used for
deploying your application
or whatever services you have used for
creating the environment for the
deployment of your application
for say we need to
deploy our
application and it needs an
windows
java environment so
whatever
resources you need to
create that environment
that will be added to this environment
list that will be listed over
this section
next we have releases option
so basically this
pipeline stores the data of your
pipelines or stages
or
tasks
and
deployments in azure pipelines that
depends you have done so far
in your applications
for your applications actually
so you can say that
it helps your team continuously deliver
software to your customers
at a
faster pace
with a very minimum
you can say lower risk
so
if you can fully automate and
automate the testing and the delivery of
your
software or applications
on
multiple
stages
or you can also set up an automated
process with approvals and on-demand
deployments
then comes
library
so again you can see the pages blank
from the name itself you can scrutinize
that will be a collection
of assets from
azure devops projects
so basically it is a collection of build
and release assets of a particular
project
so assets defined in a library can be
used in multiple bills and multiple
releases pipelines of the project
okay so all assets that are defined you
know library share a common security
model
so you can control who can define new
items in a library and you can use an
existing item that you have already
added in this library
roles are defined for eye library items
for say you have added a particular
asset or particular item
to this library segment
and you can assign a particular member
who will be working on this item
okay so
the roles are defined here for these
and these governs the operation you can
perform on those items
that person will be keeping track of
whatever changes have been made
or whatever upgradation has been made to
the particular item that has been added
to this
segment library segment
so then comes task groups
so
task groups are a way to standardize and
centrally manage deployment steps
for all applications
in your projects
so when you include a task group in your
definition and then make a change
centrally to the task group the changes
automatically reflected in all the
definitions
so we can conclude with this that a task
group allows you to encapsulate a
sequence of tasks
already defined in
you can say build or release pipelines
or into a single task group
so it just encapsulate all those
sequences of stars
so you can choose to extract the
parameters from those encapsulated tasks
as configured variables
and
abstract the rest of the task
information
so what happens is the new task group is
automatically added to the task catalog
and it is ready to be added to other
release and build pipelines
so task groups are stored at the project
level and are not accessible outside the
project school so
the task groups
will be only limited to the members who
you have assigned in this project and it
won't be
accessible to the other people or other
team members from different projects
even though they are
the member of the same organization so
you can see it's more of a private
segment
now that we have covered task groups
next we have deployment groups
so
deployment groups are only available
with classic release pipeline
and it is totally different from the
deployment jobs
it is basically a collection of
deployment related steps
defined in a yaml file to accomplish a
specific task
so
a nutshell it is a logical set of
deployment target machines
that have agents installed on each one
the deployment groups represent the
physical environment for example
testing or development or production
environment
so a development group is just another
grouping of agents much like an
agent pool you can say
so what you can do with this is you can
specify the security context and runtime
targets for the agents or you can
let yourself view live logs for each
server as a deployment take place
or you can also enable you to use
machine tags to limit deployment
to a specific set of
servers
so this was about deployment groups now
that we have covered one more service
let's move on to the next one that is
test plans
so
test plans the first one we have
is progress report
so you can
analyze with this only the progress
report will be the progress of the
project you have been working on or the
deployments you have been
doing or the tasks you have been
performing
so
so basically it lets you
analyze and view data for
more than one or an individual test
plans in a particular project
so data for test plans in migrated can
be migrated from
an on-premises azure develop server
that won't show up in this report
okay so basically this section lets you
drill down by each test plans and give
you summary of each test
plan in it
the section also lets you to navigate to
a test plan or shoot
of choice by double clicking on it okay
so
this was the progress report next we
have
runs
so basically it represents the execution
of pipelines
during a run the pipeline is processed
and agents process one or more jobs
so when you run a pipeline many things
happen under the couple while you often
won't need to know about them
occasionally
it's
useful to
have the bigger picture right
so
azure
pipelines
will get processed under this
test runs
segment so you will be able to see water
performance
is happening over here like while you're
running a pipeline you can see
the running state
the date you have started that
or what all that
running pipeline includes like jobs
steps and tasks
runs power both continuous integration
and continuous delivery pipelines
next we have
load test
so basically as your load testing is a
fully managed as azure service
that enables developers and testers to
generate high scale load with custom
apache jamie districts
and gain actionable insights
to catch and fix performance bottlenecks
at scale
basically application performance and
resiliency are more important than ever
before
so how you can
run an azure devops test
so first you need to click on it and
select a test suit that contains all the
automated tests
and
you can just choose the run test option
and it will start processing it so the
service this service basically simulates
traffic for your application
you can say regardless of
on which platform or
where it is actually hosted
so now that we have covered test plans
as well let's move on to the next one
that is artifacts so this is the last
service that is provided to your project
by azure devops
so artifacts is a
product produced during the software
development process
so it mainly consists of the project
source code dependency or binaries or
resources
that could be represented in different
layout depending on the particular
technology
so it's like an extension that makes it
easier
to discover install or publish
and may even packages in azure devops
it's basically deeply integrated with
other hubs like build so that package
management can become a seamless part
for your existing workflows
so what is exactly it is used for
so it
basically it can be used
for both public and private organization
with teams of any size it
it basically
manages your
npm or
new get packages via feeds and it allows
you to create and share your maple
it's a package management solution
indicated with your azure device
this was all about the services that is
provided to your projects so now that
you know what our services
do for your project and what are their
benefits and how they function now you
can actually plan your project and start
creating and working on it and start
deploying with the users and what all
services you want for your particular
project so what you can do is click here
on project setting
just a second
yeah you can just click on
project settings
so now what you can do is you can add in
description that uh
what your actual project is about
because like i said if you're creating
you know a health care application so
you can just give it a description that
it
is him to get related to issues queries
and helps needed and
like you're trying that particular
application with different hospitals or
healthcare organizations so you can
actually add those
information in this description
and the process which basically it is
basic or private one uh but you do get a
range of
process
for your project
depending on the visibility of like for
air child or scrub you can say
so now here you can see that only my uh
id is
attached to it as i'm the only member
here and i'm the administrator so you
can add members
here
and
scrolling down you can
now that you know what all services
uh provide you or what they provide to
your project depending on the need of
your project you can just uh select the
services you want to assign to your
particular project like per se if i
don't want both assigned to it or
you can say if i don't want the
services provided by the code
pipelines
artifacts but i don't have
uh test plans and boards as you can see
test plan is basically all the
collection of whatever you're managing
which is indirectly assigned to the
boards
so as
you remove the both the test plans also
get
removed
okay
and once
like this you can just
select what all services you want
specifically and
if you want to delete your project you
can just go ahead and delete it
so this was all about
azure develop services
and i'll show the world work in studio
we can see and how the demonstration of
how a project actually functions in this
virtual studio
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chandmi and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i am shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on aws versus
azure versus gcp talking about market
share amazon web services leads with
around 32 percent of the worldwide
public cloud share azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around 9 of the world's market
share let's talk about each of these
service providers in detail aws provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the internet
aws being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006. azure
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more additions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the
pay-as-you-go approach you pay only for
the individual services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services for aws elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java.net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost-effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage aws provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud watch
and aws cloud formation for development
we have aws code start and aws code
build for security we have iam and key
management service for microsoft azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and express
route for management tools we have azure
advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
azure advisor and network watcher for
development we have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for security we
have google cloud im and google and
cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for aws we have netflix
unilever kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe
pixar samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw
among others use microsoft azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an idea
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for long
running workloads for example you use
the vm for a month and get a discount
gcp also provides live migration of
virtual machines live migration is the
process of moving a running vm from one
physical server to another without
disrupting its availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for google cloud compared to other cloud
providers gcp provides automatic
scalability this allows a size container
scale to as many cpus as needed google
cloud storage is designed for 99.9
durability it creates server backup and
stores them in an user configure
location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than 100 an enterprise that
costs more than fifteen thousand dollars
it has certain network connectivity
issues it also has general issues when
you move to the cloud like downtime
limited control backup protection and so
on however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of microsoft azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass echo system is not as
efficient as iaas azure management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage microsoft offers three
certification paths for a variety of
technical jobs to gain certification you
must complete a series of exams and the
first one is fundamentals certification
these certifications are suitable for
those who are just getting started in
technology are considering a career
shift second is role-based certification
to begin acquiring valuable job role
abilities choose a role-based
certification third is additional
certification examine my microsoft
office technical qualifications as well
as specialist and microsoft certified
educator certifications now in each
category we have sorted the
certifications for your better
understanding in the first category
fundamental certification are microsoft
certified azure fundaments microsoft 365
certified fundamentals and microsoft
certified power platform fundamentals in
this second category role-based
certifications are microsoft 365
certified security administrator
associate microsoft certified azure
developer associate and microsoft
certified dynamics 365 sales functional
consultant associate and in the third
category additional certifications are
microsoft certified azure for sap
workload specialty microsoft certified
educator and microsoft office specialist
microsoft word expert so let's start
with the first one microsoft certified
azure fundamentals the azure fundamental
certification allows you to demonstrate
that you understand cloud concepts as
your services as your workloads as your
security and privacy and azure pricing
and support candidates should have basic
understanding of technical fundamentals
such as networking storage computation
application support and application
development candidates for the azure
fundamental certification should have a
solid understanding of cloud services
and how microsoft azure deliver them the
certification is for applicants who are
new to azure or who are just starting to
work with cloud-based solutions
and services moving ahead let's look
into its skills requirement describe
cloud concepts describe four azure
services describe core solutions and
management tools on azure describe
general security and network security
features describe identity governance
privacy and compliance features and
describe azure cost management and
service level agreements this
certification is suitable for job roles
like administrator business user
developer student technology manager and
its exam code is az900
price of this examination is 99 usd and
the renewable time is two years coming
to the next one is the microsoft 365
certified fundamental certification it
verifies that you are familiar with
microsoft 365 feature and benefits as
well as the advantages of using cloud
services the software as a service cloud
model and the microsoft 365 cloud
service these are the skills required to
earn this certification describe cloud
concepts describe core microsoft 365
services and concepts explain security
compliance privacy and trust in
microsoft 365 and describe microsoft 365
pricing and support this certification
is apt for job roles like business user
and administrator and the exam code for
this examination is ms-900 the
examination fee is 99 usd and the
renewable time is two-year next is
microsoft certified power platform
fundamentals if you're a student a
business user or a new technical
professional using your microsoft power
platform skills to better your team's
efficiency this certification can help
you advance your career to prepare for
it you only need a basic understanding
of computer technology data analytics
cloud computing and the internet
consider a fundamental certification the
initial step towards expanding your
skill set and moving on to more advanced
certifications like microsoft power
platform functional consultant and the
skill set required for this
certification are describe the business
value of power platform identify the
core components of power platform
demonstrate the capabilities of power
platform describe the capabilities of
power apps demonstrate the capabilities
of power automate demonstrate the
business value of power virtual agents
this certification is perfect for job
roles like business user functional
consultant student and its exam code is
pl 900 the examination fee for this exam
is 99 usd and its renewable time is two
years now let's dive into the second
category which was role based
certification the first certification
exam in this category is microsoft 365
certified security administrator
associate microsoft 365 security
administrators protect microsoft 365
enterprise and hybrid environments by
proactively securing them and
implementing and managing security and
compliance solutions responding to
threats and enforcing data governance
policy this exam accesses your ability
to use microsoft 365 to implement and
manage identity and access thread
protection information security and
governance and compliance features the
skills required for this certification
are implement and manage identity and
access implement and manage threat
protection implement and manage
information protection manage governance
and compliance features in microsoft
365. now this certification is perfect
for the administrator role and its exam
code is ms 500 its examination fee is
165 usd and its renewable time is again
two years then comes
microsoft certified as your developer
associate candidates for the user
developer associate certification should
have experience designing developing
testing and supporting microsoft azure
cloud applications and services
participating in all aspects of cloud
development from requirements definition
and design to develop deployment and
maintenance as well as performance
tuning and monitoring is part of its
role responsibilities now the skill set
essential for the certification are
develop azure compute solutions develop
for azure storage implement azure
security monitor troubleshoot and
optimize azure solutions connect to and
consume azure services and third-party
services now this certification is for a
job role like developer and its exam
code is az204 its examination fee is 165
usd with the renewable time of two years
moving on next is microsoft certified
dynamics 365 sales functional consultant
associate this certification could help
you advance in your career if your
functional consultant a microsoft
dynamics 365 sales professional or a
developer wishing to improve your
consulting skills it enables you to
better pitch yourself for projects and
demonstrates to your company how
dynamics 365 sales can be used to
empower sales people you have expertise
with microsoft power platform and are
familiar with dynamics 365 model driven
apps and data modeling techniques as a
candidate for this certification for
this certification skills required are
perform configuration managed core sales
tables configure additional tools and
services configure microsoft dataworks
create apps by using microsoft power
apps create and manage microsoft power
automate implement microsoft power
virtual agent chatbots integrate
microsoft power apps with other apps and
services and manage solutions now this
certification is suitable for the
functional consultant profile and the
exam code for this exam are pl 200 and
mb 210 the examination fee for this exam
is 165 usd and the renewal time is two
years now comes the third category
additional certification and the first
certification exam in this category is
microsoft certified azure for sap
workloads specialty architects or
engineers with substantial experience
and knowledge of the sap system
landscape and industry standards that
are particular to the initial migration
or integration as well as the long-term
operation of an sap solution on
microsoft azure should apply for the
certification making recommendations on
services and modifying resources as
needed for optimal resiliency
performance scale provision size and
monitoring are among the
responsibilities of an architect or
engineer for azure for sap workloads
skills required for this certification
are
migrate sap workloads to azure design
and implement an infrastructure to
support sap workloads design and
implement high availability and disaster
recovery maintain sap workloads on azure
now this certification is perfect for
job roles like administrator solution
architect and its exam code is az120
its exam fee is 165 usd with the renewal
time of two years
then comes microsoft certified educator
the microsoft certified educator mce
credential verifies that teachers
possesses the global educator technology
literacy competencies required to
provide students with a rich
personalized learning experience
educators in training instructors at
teachers education colleges and
in-service educators all benefit from
mce certification so these are the
skills required facilitate student
collaboration skill communication
self-regulation real world problem
solving and innovation facilitate
student use of information and
communication tools and use ict to be an
effective educator now this
certification is suitable for developer
and educator profiles and its exam code
is 62193 its examination fee is 127 usd
and its renewal time is two years now
comes the last but not the least one in
this category and it is microsoft office
specialist microsoft word expert earn
the microsoft office specialist word
expert certification to show that you
have the skills needed to get the most
out of word this credential demonstrate
proficiency in the creation and
management of professional papers for a
variety of purposes and scenarios the
skills essential to gain this
certification are manage document
options and settings use of advanced
editing and formatting features creating
a custom document elements and use
advanced word features now this
certification is suitable for job
profiles like business users and its
exam code is mo 101 the exam fee for
this certification is 100 usd and its
renewal time is two years so this was
all about as your certification passed
apart from this not only will you need
to learn how to design manage and
protect azure cloud systems in order to
become certified and land job but you'll
also need real hands-on experience cloud
computing refers to services like
storage databases software analytics
machine learning artificial intelligence
and so much more all of which made
accessible via the internet the cloud
tech services market is expected to grow
17.3 percent in the span of 2018 to 19
which means there's a growth from
175.8 billion dollars to a whopping 206
billion dollars in 2019 and as of 2020
it's expected that 90 of all
organizations in the world would be
using cloud services not to mention
several organizations around the world
suggest that using cloud computing
services has enabled their employees to
experiment a lot more with technologies
like machine learning and artificial
intelligence so here's what we'll be
going through today firstly we'll be
talking about who is a cloud computing
engineer the steps you need to take to
become a cloud computing engineer and
the cloud computing engineers salaries
so first off who is a cloud computing
engineer now a cloud computing engineer
is an id professional who takes care of
all the technical aspects of cloud
computing now be it design planning
maintenance and support now a cloud
computing engineer can take up a number
of different career paths this could be
that of a cloud developer security
engineer a full stack developer sysops
administrator solutions architect cloud
architect and so much more now let's
have a look at some of the major cloud
computing roles first off we have
solutions architect now these are
individuals who are responsible for
analyzing the technical environment in
which they are going to produce the
solutions the requirements and the
specifications secondly they are
required to select an appropriate
technology that satisfies set
requirements they need to estimate and
manage the usage and the operational
costs of the solutions they provide and
they need to support project management
as well as solution development next we
have sysops administrators they are
involved in deploying managing and
operating highly scalable and fault
tolerant systems they need to select an
appropriate service based on compute
security or data requirements they need
to estimate and manage usage and
operational costs and they need to be
able to migrate on-premises workloads
onto an appropriate cloud computing
platform so among both of these roles
there are certain requirements that are
remaining constant now let's have a look
at the steps you need to take to become
a cloud computing engineer your first
step is to gain proficiency in a cloud
computing platform now the first step is
to become proficient in at least one of
the three major cloud computing
platforms beat aws azure or the google
cloud platform now there are a huge
number of resources that you can find on
the internet it could be youtube videos
articles virtual or physical classrooms
and so much more now after you're done
learning you can get certified by
microsoft azure aws or the google cloud
platform now for aws you have a number
of different certifications which can be
divided into three categories which are
the foundational which is just the
basics the associate level
certifications the professional level
certifications and the specialty
certifications similarly with microsoft
azure you have certifications that
enable you to become an azure developer
associate and as your administrator
associate and azure architect
professional and a devops engineer now
most cloud computing platforms have a
free tier that you can take advantage of
these provide a number of free services
for a period of time some of which are
free forever so you can use these
platforms to your advantage and do as
much practice as you can on them now if
you want to learn more about cloud
computing you can also check out
simplylearn's youtube channel then you
can go on to the playlist section right
here and you can find comprehensive
videos on a number of different cloud
computing platforms aws and microsoft
azure our aws tutorial videos talk about
what exactly is aws how you can become
an aws solutions architect amazon ec2 s3
some of the other services and so much
more we also have detailed tutorials on
azure which talks about what exactly is
azure the certifications provided by
azure some of the services like machine
learning azure active directory and so
much more and now we're at step 2 being
experienced in at least one programming
language unlike general purpose
programming languages like c c plus plus
c sharp and so on cloud computing
requires ones that are a lot more data
oriented now some of the major
programming languages that are used in
cloud computing are go python clojure
and java now as i said before there is a
wealth of resources that you can learn
from there are free websites that you
can practice your code on like quick
code code academy and several others
there's also resources like youtube
videos as well as the option of online
or offline classes now we're at step 3
specialization you'll also need to be
well versed with a number of key
concepts these are storage and
networking now with storage you need to
know how data can be stored and where it
can be accessed from you need to know
how it can be accessed from multiple
different resources you'll also need to
have some experience with the services
provided by azure and aws like the
amazon s3 in aws and the appropriately
named azure storage from microsoft azure
with networking you need to have a
strong understanding of the networking
fundamentals as well as virtual networks
next up we have virtualization and
operating systems with virtualization
you need to know how virtual networks
which is just a combination of different
virtual machines can be used to emulate
different components in a particular
system with operating systems you need
to have a very strong understanding
operating systems like windows and linux
next up we have security and disaster
recovery now you need to understand how
data application as well as
infrastructure can be protected from
malicious attacks with disaster recovery
you need to be prepared for any
unexpected circumstance by making sure
your systems are always safe and are
regularly backed up to prevent any sort
of loss of data then we have web
services and devops now you need to have
a strong understanding of apis or
application program interfaces and web
services some amount of experience with
web design also can be of great help
with devops you need to have a strong
understanding of how cloud computing is
able to provide a centralized platform
on which you can perform testing
deployment and production for devops
automation moreover with devops you
understand the synergy that the
operations as well as the development
teams have with each other and for the
success of any project and finally
you're a cloud computing engineer now
let's have a look at the salaries of
cloud computing engineers in the united
states cloud computing engineers earn
around 116 000 dollars per annum in
india a cloud computing engineer is paid
approximately 6 lakh 66 000 rupees per
annum now how can simply learn help you
become a cloud computing engineer so
let's head on to simply learn's website
here we have the cloud architect masters
program now this deals with a number of
different courses all of which that can
help you get started in your journey to
becoming a cloud computing engineer this
master's program covers a number of
different courses like aws technical
essentials microsoft azure fundamentals
aws developer associate and so much more
it provides you 40 plus in demand skills
and 25 plus services provides you a
master's certification it has 16 plus
real-life projects and helps you get a
salary that ranges between 15 to 25 lakh
rupees per annum it also covers a
variety of tools like amazon ec2 azure
data factory virtual machines and so
much more so why don't you head on to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to getting certified and getting
ahead and with that we have come to the
end of this video on azure tutorial for
big news
i hope you found it useful and
entertaining
please ask any questions about the
topics covered in this video in the
comment box below
our experts will assist you in
addressing your problems thank you so
much for being here stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you